would you rather have everything in your  life showers weather food drinks be hot  or cold i want to say this with 45 years  of of heavy fat guy tendencies  if i could only satisfy food or  hunger or thirst it would be thirst and  to satisfy my thirst it's got to be cold  gotta be cool i'll take the cold showers  but if i can't have a [ __ ] cold  snapple or a cold soda or a cold beer  what the [ __ ] drinking hot tea after  like a basketball game  you'll never get used to a cold shower  though ever they say that's good for you  now a lot of guys are doing it rogan's  doing it yeah you know joe rogan okay he  does a polar plunge every morning yeah  there you go he's [ __ ] yeah tony  robbins he's like you can see him being  like  i don't know yeah that's not good i mean  those things are almost putting him on  his ass yeah but it's worth a cold capri  sun i can tell you that